jennifer aniston and justin theroux
announced their separation on thursday
they released a joint statement that
said it was a mutual decision and they
remain best friends now et has learned
more about what's behind the split
according to a source it all came down
to lifestyle Justin is a New Yorker and
Jen prefers la the source explained
quote he much prefers being in New York
City and that's been a major issue for
them for a long time
despite Jen growing up in New York City
the source says she never quite took to
it Justin on the other hand has deep
roots in the city not to mention all his
closest friends the other major factor
paparazzi the source tells ET Jen was
constantly hounded by photographers in
New York City so much so the paps became
an issue at their West Village apartment
which resulted in angry neighbors
according to the source the final straw
for Jen came when Justin's motorcycle
was vandalized it was covered in baloney
Jen assumed an angry neighbor did it the
source explained quote she just never
really could get settled in she wasn't
happy in New York City still the source
maintains they care deeply about one
another and wanted their marriage to
work no bad blood just differences in
lifestyle that became more clear
throughout the years
[Music]